some guy yelled at me at the airport
three days ago as if I am actually the
inventor of AI he's like I saw a video
where you said AI is going to be good
I'm like yeah he's like you're a piece
of [__]
he's like this is going to take away
jobs I'm like the tractor took away jobs
when the tractor was invented 80 of
humans on Earth worked in farms the
tractor made it not have to be that when
Google and Yahoo came along they took
away the Yellow Pages nobody feels bad
for the people that were selling the
Yellow Pages because he didn't own a
taxi Medallion you weren't mad at Uber
you were happy with Uber but when it
comes for you now it's a [__] problem
people are spending all their time
scared that the AI is going to take my
creative job away without realizing what
it's going to do is take away the
mundane and elevate your skill sets I
think we need to start leaning a little
more into optimism and I believe when I
see all these beautiful places in the
crowd that every one of them are capable
of adjusting to new truths as long as
they start with realizing that they're
capable of adjusting to new truths